[Music]
from indie game developer Scott cofen
prove that we all got to start
somewhere comes an adaptation of his
biggest hit that pulled off the sets
animatronics and deep cut references
that Define the franchise but forgot to
follow one simple rule
don't make everything else
boring in what feels like more than five
nights at
Freddy's do you pay rent then you're
probably too old to know about FNAF the
game equivalent of a Jack In The
Box that's either a game about watching
screens until monsters pop
out or a metag game about grown men
screaming until view counts go
up but the real reason behind its
staying power is the steady drip of dark
and twisted
lore okay I'll put it this way for the
olds imagine pong but after every round
they hint that left paddle got
molested when you need to make a 6 and
1/2t Bunny look menacing you call 5 1/2t
actor Josh Hutchinson he's playing Mike
taker of his sister ABS hey abs abs abs
abs you ready Mike's your standard dead
be dead archetype in brother form I
don't care do whatever you want I'm
hardly fit to be raising a kid we want
ABY okay because he's too busy searching
for his other missing sibling by taking
pills and hoping the answers come to him
in a dream yeah I actually tried that
for my four clipped operator test it's
not going to work when he's not asleep
which is most of the movie Mike's
hanging out with this Dr cop MD
professor at large can I uh help you
officer I'm a certified EMT wow you
really didn't do your homework did you
as they join forces to protect his
sister from a ridiculous over-the-top
villain no not Freddy you a wretched rot
little beast not him either this
degenerate is who they entrust with the
well-being of a mentally ill child there
she is and Jane an evil caricature who's
scheming to take Abby away
because um hm Mike's broke so it's not
for the child support why would you hire
a lawyer in a goon squad to take a kit
she doesn't even like maybe she's the
Killer maybe she took out Mike's family
maybe she's the yellow bunny Abby tried
to warn us about I mean obviously not
but if we stretch that out for 16 more
minutes we got ourselves a film Theory
it's just a theory meet the animatronics
haunting Freddy Fazbear's pizzeria that
shockingly came out looking pretty legit
oh that's why controlling these ghost
child corpse mascot T duckin is William
Aton yet another American business owner
trying to automate his Workforce played
by fan favorite Matthew Lillard who's
completed his quadrilogy of gangly guys
obsessed with death together these
monsters will terrify your imagination
and only your imagination because this
PG-13 movie comes pre-censorship
but did so well at the box office we're
sure to get 100 sequels I always come
back and every indie game with an
annoying fan base is about to get the
big screen treatment no no
[Applause]
no
starring Charles unemployment cheese
pilot the Ella Abby or Garrett will have
to do it again we have Jennifer Lawrence
at home now let's take off this mask and
see who you really are
why it's old man Lillard don't tell Mike
the Babysitter's Dead Aunt I a stinker
scare Bear
stare Oxy Cotton Tail bird bird bird the
bird the turd what does the fox slay and
jump scare just kidding jump scare never
mind jump scare made you look jump scare
got you again jump scare okay I'm done
and jump
scare nights of the Living Dead
[Music]
kids it's not just their ghosts that are
inside of those machines it's their
bodies why would he stuff the bodies
into big animal suits instead of just
cooking them into the pizzas the
children's menu pun is right
there I'm hopeless and awkward and
desperate for love it was also the night
that the skeletons came to life pizza
pizza go in tummy Mis so hungy me so
hungy M they're making me say weird
again